After two weeks of denying that anything said
in the impeachment hearings was true. Donald
Trump went on Fox news and he admitted to
the entire thing for the first time publicly
linking the supposedly corruption investigations
that he wanted Ukraine to do to the military
aid.
This is the first time it's happened publicly.
You can't write a more ridiculous. If this
were a screenplay, it would be rejected immediately
because it's too over the top. It's not believable
and yet it's the reality that we live in.
So let me explain to you what took place Donald
Trump on Friday, uh, promoted and appearance
on Fox and friends after smearing impeachment
witnesses. After denying that anything inappropriate
happened, saying quote, I will be interviewed
on Fox and friends this morning at 8:00 AM.
I know that there's not much to talk about,
but we will try to keep the conversation going,
enjoy. And indeed, it was an interesting conversation
because in this interview, Donald Trump admitted
to the entire thing, not on purpose. I don't
think he even realizes that he admitted to
the entire thing. I don't know that the average
Fox news viewer realizes that Trump admitted
to the entire thing that he spent the two
weeks of impeachment hearings denying in this
clip. He admits that he asked on the phone
call for Ukraine to investigate Biden and
he says, I did ask them, and why should we
give them hundreds of millions of dollars
linking the investigation requests to the
hundreds of millions of dollars in aid for
the first time publicly,
and I still want to see that server. You know,
the FBI has never gotten that server. That's
a big part of this whole thing. Why did they
give it to a Ukrainian company?
Are you sure they did that? Are you sure they
gave it to you? Crane?
No, that's what the word is and that's what
I asked actually in my phone call, if you
know, I mean, I asked that very point blank
because we're looking for corruption, this
tremendous corruption. We're looking for,
why should we be giving hundreds of millions
of dollars to countries when there's this
kind of corruption? And if you look at my
call, I said, you know, corruption. I think
he said it to me. He's looking, he got elected
on the basis of corruption.
Trump, without realizing it, admits that that
is exactly what he did. We're looking for
corruption. We asked them to do it, and why
should we give them the money implying of
course, if they don't want to help, look for
corruption, meaning chase down some absurd
conspiracy theory and then use it to smear
Joe Biden. Why would we give them money? This
went completely over the heads of so many
people that were watching this, but this is
Trump blurting out that the thing that he's
been denying for weeks is absolutely true.
Here's another rambling moment from the interview
where Trump said, I always want corruption.
It was a weird moment.
Go at your ambassador to the United, uh, to
the EU. Uh, mr Sunderland in his opening statement
said that there was quid pro quo. There was
quid pro quo. He said, because, uh, you wanted
an investigation into corruption in exchange
for a visit to the white house or something
like that.
Yeah. Well, that's total nonsense. I do want
always corruption. I say that to anybody.
Why should we give money to a country that's
known corrupt? It's a very corrupt country.
I mean, I love the people in Ukraine. I know
Ukrainian people. They're great people, but
it's known as being the third most corrupt
country in the world.
Okay. So I mean, I guess it seems pretty clear
that Trump is not saying what he meant to
say there. Is it a Freudian slip? Who knows?
But once again, bringing up, why should we
give them money unless they do what we say,
unless they do what we ask them to do, which
is investigate Joe Biden. He is admitting
to the whole thing. Yet again, without even
realizing it, he's not admitting to it in
the way that we might imagine would happen.
But this is Trump publicly linking these vague
corruption concerns, which are of course code
for investigate Joe and Hunter Biden linking
that to the hundreds of millions of dollars
in military aid. The other thing that's not
being mentioned enough is if Trump is insisting
that Ukraine is rife with corruption. I want
to say this again. If Trump believes Ukraine
is just corruption Laden, why would you insist
on Ukraine investigating corruption?
Why would you trust someone so corrupt to
investigate corruption for you? It doesn't
make any sense. Then there's one other really
funny moment from this interview. When Trump
did that CrowdStrike server conspiracy theory
thing, even Fox news host Steve Doocy had
to say, are you sure about that? And if you
are watching, you will notice that the look
on Ainslie Earhart's face, it never moves.
During this entire interview, Brian Kilmeade
starts doing his sort of confused face and
Steve Doocy feels compelled to because he
knows that what Trump is saying is bogus.
He feels compelled to say, are you sure about
that? Take a look.
Have the server right from the DNC. Democratic
national committee has the FBI went in and
they told him, get outta here. You're not
kidding. We're not giving it to you. They
gave the server to CrowdStrike or whatever
it's called, which is a country which is a
company owned by a very wealthy Ukrainian
and I still want to see that server. You know,
the FBI has never gotten that server. That's
a big part of this whole thing. Why did they
give it to a Ukrainian company?
Are you sure they did that? Are you sure they
gave it to you? Crane?
Well, that's what the word is and that's what
I asked actually in my phone call of, you
know, I mean I asked it very point blank because
we're looking for corruption. Brian Kilmeade
I think is smarter than the other two and
he realizes with that that you can tell this
is not a good thing for Donald Trump to be
saying. This entire fiasco went on for 50
minutes in a bizarre, rambling interview filled
with self-incrimination, filled with lies.
But understand Trump believes it's smart for
him to testify on his own behalf. That's why
last week when Donald Trump said, I might
be interesting interested in testifying in
this impeachment hearing, I told you his lawyers
will do everything possible so that he doesn't
because just like in this interview he will
self incriminate and he doesn't even realize
it. He believes that he can talk his way out
of anything and come away convincing everybody
in the room to go over to his point of view
and case in point, Trump did this interview
on Fox news and did not even realize that
he admitted for the first time publicly that
indeed the investigations he wanted Ukraine
to do were indeed linked to the hundreds of
millions of dollars in aid.
People are getting death threats against themselves
and their families for coming forward to testify
about this and Trump just blurts it out on
live television and of course otherwise completely
incoherent throughout the interview. If I
mean this is an aside, it's an aside scandal.
If Barack Obama had ever done one incoherently
rambling word salad interview like this, Republicans
would have immediately called for Barack Obama's
removal under the 25th amendment to the constitution.
Trump does it almost every time he speaks
publicly, and not only do they stand behind
him, they are almost smitten with his public
persona and his public presence. It is something
else and I don't know when and how we are
going to come out of it. I've suggested some
of the ways and I've talked about the uphill
battle that it will be, but this is going
to be a a big, big recovery process for the
United States if we are ever to undertake
it and complete it. And I hope that we do.
I hope that we do. Make sure you're following
the David Pakman show on Instagram at David
Pakman show. While you're there, follow me
at David's,
Josh Pacman. We'll take
a
quick break and be back with much gifts